PETER HAZLEHURST: Hi.
Good morning.
Wow, super loud.
I guess everyone's still sort
of reeling from a bit of the
excitement earlier
this morning.
And it's kind of fun to see so
many of you guys here today.
I'm Peter Hazlehurst.
I look after the product
management side of our
payments group here at Google.
And I'm really, really excited
to be here with you to talk
about some of the new things
that are coming from our
Google Wallet platform and in
particular some of the new
APIs that we're launching
today.
What's kind of funny is that
I've been doing this stuff for
almost 20 years now.
And I was reflecting on the fact
that my first piece of
banking, or payment software
I wrote in 1993.
And our objective then was to
actually get rid of legacy
software for mainframes
that was 10 years old.
And I was talking to my team
who were preparing for a 20
year anniversary.
And the software is
still running.
It's 20 years old.
And now I'm the legacy
developer.
So it's kind of sad, kind of
fun, and kind of interesting
at the same time.
But there you go.
So anyway, it's a pretty
exciting day here at Google.
And there's a lot of
things going on.
And I want to get into some of
the new stuff that we're
bringing to market.
Just as a little bit of a level
set, one of the things
that we struggle with in
payments is getting people to
change behavior and adopting
new ideas and new concepts.
And one of the things that
we've noticed really
interesting lately is the pace
of change in mobile is really
dramatic and really quick.
One of the things we'd heard
earlier is that people just
wouldn't use the internet, at
all, for doing financial
transactions back in
the late '90s.
But that's moved on.
And now pretty much everybody's
using their credit
card and making payments and
doing stuff online these days.
But it's even moving faster in
mobile and that's what's
really exciting about what we're
doing here with Wallet.
So things are changing.
Things are moving really,
really quickly.
And what's really interesting
is how mobile's changing all
the different ways we interact
and how we work together.
I think, perhaps, most
personally is
the bathroom usage.
And at our house we made sure
we had Wi-Fi access points
with good range so that we could
do work and keep going
at the same time.
But it's pretty interesting.
As part of the Payments team,
one of the things we try and
optimize for is making
sure that the
phones work in stores.
And that you can have a great
experience shopping and
looking for things and
purchasing stuff.
And what's unique about what
we're doing is we're starting
to see an incredible number of
people looking for discounts,
and coupons, and offers, and
savings, and things like that
with their phones.
And so what's nice is that's
level setter, it's a stage
setting for some of the work
we did and why we brought
Google Wallet into the market.
So Google Wallet is, as many
as you guys know, an
opportunity for the consumer
to use their
phone to make a payment.
And we thought that the best way
to do that was to couple
things with NFC, where we
actually have the ability to
see and experience in real time
a connection from the
phone to the terminal and
out into the cloud
to make things happen.
Google Wallet's been going
really, really great.
We're really excited about
our progress today.
And as part of this objective
our first and foremost goal
was to kick-start an ecosystem
and to get things going.
We were the first guys
to make it happen.
And it's kind of fun to see a
bunch of our colleagues in the
industry starting to catch on
to what seems like a pretty
good idea of making payments and
doing fun things with your
cell phone, as a way to do
commerce and things like that
around the internet.
So thinking about why this
is so hard and what the
challenges are.
It's important to realize
how many players get to
participate in the ecosystem and
how many different sorts
of guys have a role
in what we do.
And the real challenge here is,
as part of Google Wallet,
we have to bring all of these
teams together to agree on
standards, to agree on how
transactions should process,
to make things work together.
And it's nontrivial.
Because everybody thinks
they own the customer.
And every one thinks
the user is theirs.
And at Google we fundamentally
believe you are the user and
you get to choose.
Which is why it's kind of
exciting to see a little bit
more competition
in the market.
And people are more interested
in giving different ways of
paying with things.
But it's nice to see that
there's opportunity for lots
of different people to
participate in the ecosystem
and still create great value
for the consumer.
But don't underestimate how
difficult this is to get
everybody from the banks to
the people that make the
phones to the retailers to put
all of their different systems
together and make it work.
So talking a little bit about
momentum, as I think you guys
heard in the keynote.
One of the things we're really,
really proud of is the
acceleration of NFC
in the real world.
And to give you a sense of what
that looks like, when we
kicked this thing off and we
started thinking about Google
Wallet back in 2010, there was
a pretty small number of
phones out there and a pretty
small number of terminals.
I actually remember working at
Nokia when we launched one of
the first NFC phones
back in 2004.
And right then we thought
the world was
going to take on fire.
It was going to be three years
and there'd be tens of
millions of phones out there.
Didn't quite happen so much.
But what I'm really, really
excited to reemphasize is
we're now launching and adapting
more than a million
NFC phones a week.
So the ecosystems growing really
fast and the rate of
growth is even faster than
you would imagine.
You can see the number of
terminals that are available
on a worldwide basis is growing
really, really fast.
And we're really excited about
the fact that there's going to
be so many more places that you
can use your phone to make
a payment and have things
just work beautifully.
In the last two quarters we've
launched six new phones
powered by Google Wallet.
And that's really exciting.
And we think we've got tons more
exciting products that
are coming out towards
the end of this year.
So I guess the next thing is,
How have we been going?
What have we been doing?
In Google Wallet there's been a
bunch of excitement, a bunch
of adapting, and listening to
consumers and to you the
developers, and everybody out
there with our products.
We pushed out 14 revisions in
nine months, largely in
response to a bunch of consumer
feedback of wanting
to get better value out of their
phone and integrating
offers into the service.
We added a whole bunch of new
features and capabilities
around transaction history and
support of different sorts of
experiences in the store.
We listened and we learned to
the complexity of making sure
that the point-of-sale devices
actually work, in reality
versus just in theory.
And you just won't believe the
number of challenges from the
fact that some of the devices,
while they have power on,
aren't actually connected
to anything.
And so we had people tapping
their phones and saying,
What's going on?
And literally, it was like this,
connected with power but
not actually connected to
anything on the other side.
So we've built a lot of smarts
into the app to react to those
situations.
And as a result the ability for
payments to come through
our system is improving
day by day.
We've also listened and
adapted to the various
concerns around the security
of our product.
And we still feel very, very
confident that this is the
safest way to pay and the best
solution for you as an end
user to make payments
in the industry.
But what we wanted to do then,
just very quickly, is give you
a sense of how's this going
with consumers.
So we set up an event where we
gave people a chance to try
Google Wallet.
And this is a little bit of the
real-time feedback we've
heard from them.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-I can't wait.
I am so excited about this.
This is like--
I'm gonna do it.
-Wow.
-Look at that.
-Oh my gosh.
It's so cool.
[LAUGHTER]
-Wow.
-[INAUDIBLE].
-OMG!
OMG!
[LAUGHS]
Thank you Google Wallet.
PETER HAZLEHURST: So the
exciting thing is, and what we
keen to do here at Google is
make sure we have magical
experiences with consumers.
And what we were getting out of
Google Wallet is this sense
that we're starting to deliver
on some of the
benefits to the consumer.
That we can help them save money
by discovering and using
existing deals.
We're giving them a way to store
all of their loyalty
cards and payment cards
in the cloud.
We're giving them the financial
control that they want.
And just this whole beautiful
experience of when you tap
your phone, the payment
just works.
But the challenge for us is
dealing with concerns the
consumers have around security,
and also dealing
with the fact that it doesn't
necessarily work everywhere.
And so this is part of what
we're trying to solve with
Google Wallet and some of the
new things we're doing.
And one of the things we've
started to do as we've adapted
to the market, is adapt
to the fact that real
world is really important.
But people have told us they
want to use their Wallet
everywhere.
So we've pushed everything
up into the cloud.
Google Wallet in the cloud is
now available so that you can
do purchases all throughout
Google, on Play, Chrome Store.
You can buy books, you can buy
music, you can buy games.
And it's also now available on
merchant sites, and in-app
payments, and other sorts
of solutions.
And you can see a little bit
more demo of some of the new
stuff we're doing with
in-app payments
later on this afternoon.
Fundamentally, everything you
do with Google Wallet is
stored in the cloud, made
available across all the
places we make Google
available.
So going forward we said to
ourselves, There must be
another solution and
another concern.
And the question is, How do you
store things like coupons
and tickets and gift cards and
all of these other things that
you keep track of in
your daily life?
And that's where we started
to evolve Google.
And what we wanted to start to
focus in on is, How do I keep
track of all of this
information?
And how do I make it easy
to save it in my wallet?
And that's what we're here
to talk about right now.
So we're talking about a new
feature, a new capability
called Save-to-Wallet.
And Save-to-Wallet is a part
of our platform, our open
ecosystem, that makes it
possible for you as an end
user to save different pieces of
content that you see around
the net to your Wallet.
And then use it in different
places wherever you go.
The implementation of which
we're offering right now is
two key APIs.
First of all, for saving
offers to your Wallet.
This is the ability to go on
any website, anywhere, and
save a discount or coupon
or some sort of savings.
Store it in the Wallet.
And if you need to, you can show
and scan and make it easy
for the cashier to
receive it or.
Or If you're a merchant, and you
know you support NFC, you
can actually also
save NFC-related
offers to your Wallet.
So this is kind of exciting.
And then we're also launching
Save to Wallet for payment
cards, which is even
more interesting.
But we'll get to that
in a second.
So let's talk about
Save-to-Wallet for offers.
In the past, we've had a pretty
easy model for our own
teams at Google to support
putting discounts and savings
in your Wallet.
And that's been working
really, really well.
But what we're excited about
right now is the ability for
you guys to offer the
ability to save
things on your websites.
Or as merchants, you could save
it on your website, too,
and get it out into your
Wallet and then be used
elsewhere across the internet.
Why would you want to do that?
Because it's a frictionless way
of saving these offers to
your Wallet.
It makes it really, really easy
to redeem them and show
them onto the merchant and
make a transaction flow.
And we're pretty confident about
the redemption side of
things, that it's going
to work great.
So what I'm going to do now is
give you a bit of a demo of
how this looks as an end
consumer and set things up a
little bit here.
There we go.
All right.
So here's the deal.
Some of you may know, I have
just been blessed with twins
about 18 months ago.
And believe it or not, my wife
who's never seen Star Wars
named them Luke and Leia.
And so Luke and Leia, my two
kids, are particularly fond of
pies and cakes and
stuff like that.
And I fancy myself as
a bit of a baker.
So I'm pretty keen to go
shopping and doing baking and
stuff like that.
So imagine here I am,
on allrecipes.com.
And I found this awesome example
of a pie that I might
want to make.
And you know what?
I was kind of in trouble a
little bit, because I turned
40 and I think life is sort of
coming on the down slope.
And it was kind of interesting,
so I was thinking
to myself, I don't really have
time to make a cake.
The team's keeping
me pretty busy.
So how about this?
There's an offer here for some
awesome Biscoff cookies.
So I'm going to click
on that offer.
And what you can see here is an
offer being presented out
of the Walgreen's website.
And we're really excited about
working with Walgreen's and
Biscoff to make this offer.
And so you can see here, it's a
pretty standard offer with a
bunch of capabilities.
And sitting down at the bottom
is this cool button called
Save-to-Wallet.
And all you do is you click on
the Save-to-Wallet button.
Not exactly rocket science.
And as an end user, that's it.
Done.
Done and dusted.
And then you say, Well,
now what I do with it?
Well, I should have
got an email here.
Excellent.
So you get a bit of a
notification that something's
happened in your Wallet.
And for what it's worth
these are real offers.
So if any of you guys have
Galaxy Nexuses, or other NFC
phones, you can tap the offer
downstairs and get a free
awesome set of cookies.
And then what happens is if
you go into your Wallet.
And remember that whole
thing how we're nice
and safe and secure?
So I'm going to put in my PIN,
which you guys can now have.
This is not my phone.
My phone is over there.
I don't how many of you guys
have seen this stuff before.
So I'll just quickly browse
through a little bit of the
capabilities.
Google Wallet lets you have
things like credit cards, and
we also have a prepaid
gift card.
We can also store all the gift
cards in there as well.
We have rewards support.
So you can store all your fancy
reward cards that you
use all the time,
loyalty cards.
We have transactions.
And let me show you
about the offers.
So here you can see I've
got the NFC offer here.
You can see it's enabled
for NFC.
Do you guys see that?
And I have nothing more to do
than to-- imagine here I am
walking into the store.
I make a payment.
And you hear the beautiful
little W. Oops, sorry, a
little bit off the screen.
And there you go.
So what happened was transaction
was transmitted
from my phone.
The offer was present.
The merchant accepted it.
I've got a nice little
geolocation on where the
[INAUDIBLE] transaction
occurred.
I could write a note.
Give to the kids.
This is not running Jelly Bean,
which is why it doesn't
do the predictions.
All right.
And that was it.
Super, super simple.
So that Save-to-Wallet button
can exist anywhere on the web.
And it will save it into a
Google user's account.
And then can be redeemed
throughout the web.
To prove that this was actually
working and to prove
that there's proof of life of
Luke and Leia, I actually did
an end-to-end test of the
product, including live
redemption.
And you can see Leia there
munching away on the cookie
with here Google-branded
sweatshirt
on, which is awesome.
The dog is in the background,
he ate most of them.
Anyway, so to give you a sense
of what this is, it's really,
really simple.
All you need to do is
drop in the button
snippet on your web page.
If as an end user you weren't
logged in to Google.
And if you weren't running
Chrome, shame on you.
But if, in fact, you weren't
running on Chrome, it will pop
up a Google login.
So say if you're
on your iPhone.
We're gonna then drop
in a proxy iframe.
We're going to log in and get
a cross-site scripting token
to make sure we're not getting
hacked and so forth.
And it's a simple API call.
And you're done.
It's really, really,
really easy.
And this is the critical
point.
What does it look like from
a code perspective?
Drop in the JavaScript.
Easy, easy.
Tell us a little bit about what
the offer is that you
want to do, in a minimal,
rendable format.
Pretty easy.
Indicate whether you want us
to do something over NFC.
And I'll show you what a
show-and-scan version of that
looks like.
And tell us a little bit about
yourself, where's the
information?
And then at the bottom,
don't forget to put
the button on there.
There's nothing else
to it guys.
If you guys can't code
this in half a day,
there's something wrong.
And just in case you wanted
to do a QR code, or
show-and-scan, under the type
code you just enter that
information.
Very, very easy.
That's it.
That's how you save an
offer to the Wallet.
You make it super,
super smart.
And what we've suddenly done
there is made it possible for
anybody to put information
into the Wallet.
This is part of a whole suite
of APIs that we're doing to
open up the Wallet.
Perhaps more interestingly, is
the fact that we're also
offering Save-to-Wallet
for payment cards.
And so think about this.
Right now, we have millions and
millions of users creating
Wallets throughout the internet
for things like
Google Play and so forth.
And one of the things that we
hear back from them is it's
kind of a pain to add their
credit card information and
make sure it's kept up-to-date
with their bank.
In our app, we'll actually
disable a card that gets
expired, things like that.
And so what we tried to do is
think about how could we do
this better and different.
And we've tested this out.
And most people are really,
really comfortable logging
into online banking and to their
credit card websites and
things like that.
And we said to ourselves, Well,
if their already logged
into online banking, why don't
we take the idea of
Save-to-Wallet and put it
inside online banking?
So for example, we've partnered
up with Discover to
make a first example of how
this is going to work.
And the concept here is
really simple, again.
The focus is on a very, very
easy lightweight button that
you can drop in to your app,
or into your website, that
allows information about credit
cards and and other
sorts of payment instruments
to be pushed
into the Google Wallet.
So let's have a look at what
that does and how it works.
Why would you do it?
Obviously, because it's easy
to get to as a user.
And one of the things we heard
from our banking partners is
getting information into
Google Wallet has
been hard in the past.
So we wanted to simplify
things tremendously.
So let me go to my awesome
new Nexus 7.
And in the spirit of, somewhat
of proof, I'm gonna go to
Google Wallet and make sure--
I don't exactly have one, this
is the true demo test.
You can see the login
thing over here.
OK.
So we should be logged in.
And, oops, there we go.
Let's have a look at
my payment methods.
And you can see a bunch of
credit cards, lots of
different sorts of things.
And no, it's not my
full card number.
So no, you can't go make
transactions on my behalf.
But you can see, clearly,
no Discover card.
So I'm going to go
to Discover.
And you can see they have
a secure card log on.
I will give you my user
name, just in case you
wanted to do that.
But I'm going to
take the camera
off-screen for a second.
Trust but verify.
And for those of you knew me
from Yodlee, the password is
not topsecret1.
OK.
There we go.
So I'm gonna log in now.
All right.
And then what I'm going
to do is I'm gonna go
over to this new tab.
So sorry, just to make sure.
Couple of credit cards,
a few little
transactions here and there.
I'm going to go to a new tab.
Now I'm gonna go and add
this in a new tab.
Let's hopefully do that.
Oh.
Can you feel it?
Let's see here.
Oh there we go.
OK.
So you can see here,
right, we've got a
landing page from Discover.
And the reason we're using this
local address is just so
you guys don't hack the
new URL, which isn't
quite public yet.
But it is for reals.
and you can see here, as a bank
or an issuer you get the
opportunity to put some
marketing information up, like
what is it, why would I do it,
what saves me time and money,
and where can I shop.
This is sort of an indicator of
how to use Google Wallet.
But I'm going to hit
Add Your Card.
And hopefully it's going
to then ask me, Do
I want to log in?
And what it's actually doing
here is it's asking me as an
end user, Do I give permission
from Google to Discover to
talk to my account through
open authentication?
So as an end user, you're
always in charge.
And this is the critical
point.
So we say, Yeah, I'm
going to do that.
And we log in.
And there we go, done, pretty
straightforward.
Theoretically I got a message.
I also got some Google+
messages, awesome.
There we go.
You can see I added my card to
my Wallet, great opportunity
for banks and issuers to
message back to their
consumers about what's
going on.
And let's go over to Play and
just prove that everything
made it all the way through.
I think you guys saw some of
the new movies and TV.
So let's go and see what
we've got to buy.
Loading, loading, loading.
Let's buy some new TV show.
I haven't seen The
Walking Dead.
So let's buy the whole season,
see what happens.
Why would you watch it in less
than HD on your new Nexus 7?
OK.
And we're going to do a little
bit of work here getting a
list of all my credit cards and
all of that sort of thing.
Taking a few seconds.
And I'm going to go
to my Discover.
And I Accept and Buy.
And that was it.
Really, really lightweight.
Really, really simple.
And we just did something that
has sort of confounded the
industry for ages and ages.
How do you share information
safely and securely between a
bank or a credit card issuer
and a third party Wallet,
which is what Google
Wallet is?
All with the trust, and all with
the control, in the hands
of the user.
Not in the hands of the bank,
not in the hands of anybody
else but the user in charge.
How does it work?
Exactly the same way--
oh, slide [INAUDIBLE].
There we go.
So we basically saw I was logged
in to online banking,
pretty straightforward.
We do a little bit of
extra OAuth setup.
So this is putting the
user in control.
So unlike saving a coupon,
or a cookie, or
something like that--
we pretty much think saving
a cookie is a
safe sort of action.
Pushing credit cards, things
like that, a little bit more
user control needed.
So we'll give that
to the user.
We authorize the token and then
it's very, very simple.
Again, you package up the
information you want to send
to Google and send
it off to us.
So what's it look like?
Again, simplicity
is the key here.
A little bit of code here
in an example in Python.
So for those of you
keeping track on
different language styles.
Get some security encryption
stuff set up, no big deal.
Tell us what you're
going to do.
So we need to get information
about what type of card you're
going to add to the Wallet.
Whether it's a credit
card, or debit card,
or things like that.
What sort of type
of card it is.
You'll notice that we're
actually pretty keen on
encrypting the card data.
So if you send us card number
information that's not
encrypted, we're going
to barf on that.
And then we give you a little
bit of opportunity to put some
information around last four
digits, expiration
date, and so on.
That's what shows up in the
clear for the user.
So that if they have lots of
cards in their Wallet they
know which one to pick.
And then very, very simple,
send us the request.
And get the response.
It falls into the one-to-two
days of integration time
versus the six-to-12 months
traditional integration time
for a credit card issuer or a
bank connecting to Google.
We think this is a huge, huge
enabler and a way for
consumers to get more
information stored in their
Wallet in a safe and secure
way, where they
get to control things.
So you can imagine that this
sort of first step with offers
and payment cards isn't the end
of where we're going with
Save-to-Wallet.
And you should watch closely
for new and exciting other
sorts of content that you can
save into your Wallet really,
really soon.
We think that increasing the
ability for consumers to get
offers in their Wallet is
a key benefit for them.
And we know that you guys have
a lot of content that you'd
like to push to them, in terms
of savings and discounts.
But then going forward, adding
the payment cards is one of
the key barriers that we're
going to lift that makes it
much easier for the consumer to
start getting their Wallet
and be active with it.
And that's one of the key
things we're focused on.
So, again, this is where
we are today.
We've got a whole bunch of other
stuff that we're going
to talk about later on related
to commerce and
other aspects of Google.
And we've also got a bunch of
new, exciting announcements
around digital goods that's
coming towards this afternoon.
And we're happy to come and
redeem some free cookies for
you later on.
So thanks for your time.
Very short and sweet,
like the APIs.
Wanted to make it easy for
you to both consume the
information in this
session and almost
get you back on schedule.
So got a few minutes for
questions if you guys have
anything you want to.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
PETER HAZLEHURST: Hi.
That was quick.
AUDIENCE: I have a
quick question.
You showed how easy it
was to add a coupon.
Can the business follow
the follow through?
Where's the analytics on that?
Would it be part of
like the Google Ad
dashboard or something?
PETER HAZLEHURST: I'm sorry.
I didn't quite understand
the question.
AUDIENCE: So how can a business
track how many people
use those coupons?
Is there anything like that?
PETER HAZLEHURST: Oh I see
what you're saying.
Yeah.
So there's an Offers setup
dashboard that allows you to
see all the different coupons
and offers that you've made.
If you're doing it on Google
and through Google.
But otherwise you're just
going to get redemption
signals sent back to
you afterwards.
Yeah, Hi.
AUDIENCE: Hi, oh sorry.
I also work with
the Paypal API.
And I'm wondering if anybody
here, because I don't think
this is a question for you,
but maybe there's some--
Remember Google Checkout
had an API, too, right?
And Paypal allows a developer
to make a payment.
And some of it goes to
developers some of it goes to
the company, like a
three-way deal.
And Google Checkout doesn't
seem to have that ability.
So I'm wondering if I could ask
someone, is there any old
Google Checkout API
people around?
PETER HAZLEHURST: I actually
don't know if there are any
old Google Checkout people--
AUDIENCE: Or not old,
but I think--
PETER HAZLEHURST: I think the
focus is let's look on what
the new stuff that we're
making possible.
And in particular things like
in-app payments which may be a
solution to things you need.
And if you want to come to our
session, or come to our
sandbox, we'd be happy to
talk to you in more
detail about that.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Thank you.
PETER HAZLEHURST:
Thanks Yes, sir.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Where exactly the information
is stored?
Is it on your cloud?
I mean, all those credit card
details and everything?
PETER HAZLEHURST: Yeah,
great question.
So the information is stored
in the cloud and stored in
Google data centers
around the world.
And so that's how we can make
it available throughout all
the different places where
Google Wallet is
made for end users.
AUDIENCE: Could we get a
physical printout of all the
offers you saved in
the Google Wallet?
PETER HAZLEHURST:
As an end user?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Just to go to stores
and redeem them?
Like, all the Walgreen's
coupons, or--
PETER HAZLEHURST: So I'm pretty
sure you could print
your screen from the website
person of Google Wallet.
So we have a place where
you can see all the
offers that you have.
And in addition, the offers also
support show-and-scan.
So if the merchant didn't
have NFC, which some
don't, that's OK.
You just turn the phone around
and show the coupon.
And maybe it has to offer code
and stuff like that.
And they can just type it
in and read it our.
So yeah, we support that.
Hi.
AUDIENCE: Can you speak for a
second about the transaction
information that you guys might
have access to after
someone processes this?
If this is integrated, a
retailer decides to integrate
it online, can you speak to sort
of the data visibility
you have into the actual
transaction?
Items purchased, or offers
redeemed, that kind of stuff?
PETER HAZLEHURST: So I think
if you're asking is, Are we
looking at the data and
understanding it and using it
for ads and other
sorts of things?
And the way things work with
Google Wallet is there's a
general transaction store, which
is really focused on
what the consumer can see.
And then there's information
that we will give back to the
retailer, if they're the
creator, if the transaction
occurs in their context.
And pretty much that's the sort
of continuum of who gets
to see the information.
We're very much focused on
letting the user feel
confident that the information
we store is just for them and
for their use.
OK?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Just a follow-up
question on the last one.
So is Google taking
responsibility in terms of
fraudulent use, or whatever
happens to those details, or
like wrong transactions, or
all those kind of things?
Or how's it going to work out?
PETER HAZLEHURST: So sitting
behind Google Wallet is all
the classic security and fraud
monitoring capabilities that
we've had for very long time.
And we look and make sure that
transactions seem good to us.
And if they seem like they're
going to be bad, we'll cancel
them before they go through to
the merchant, if need be.
If the consumer has a problem,
their recourse is
they can call us.
And we will see if
we can help them.
But ultimately, they can also
call to a merchant and see if
they need to solve
issue there.
So we're making it easy for
the consumer to see, with
transparency, who's
participating in the
transaction.
And giving them the access to
the information they need to
resolve the concern.
Yes, sir.
AUDIENCE: I just got a quick
question of clarification for
the coupons.
So you can offer it on your
website, but the actual
redemption only happens
offline?
PETER HAZLEHURST: So the
question is you can offer it
on your website and the
redemption happens offline?
Yes that's what's
happening today.
So you can imagine using your
Google Wallet phone as a way
to redeem that coupon.
AUDIENCE: I had a question about
the point-of-sale or
merchant side.
Are there APIs available to
integrate the redemption into
a point-of-sale system?
PETER HAZLEHURST: There
is, actually.
So we have another group in our
team that works with the
big point-of-sale retail
software companies.
And we'd be happy to talk
to you about it.
So we've got a deep integration
already with IBM,
for example.
And that allows for complete
understanding, at the
line-item level, every
transaction, and each
different SKU, and whether you
get different reward points,
and so on based on that.
AUDIENCE: Great.
Thanks.
PETER HAZLEHURST: Sure.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
If we lose the phone,
how do we ask
Google to wipe the data?
PETER HAZLEHURST: So right now,
you just call 1-800--
whatever our number is
for Google Wallet.
And they will do it
over the phone.
If you lose your phone,
how would you call?
Good question.
Probably use another
phone to call.
Assuming you can actually call
Google, then we can delete the
data for you.
And we're looking at new
solutions in the future to
make it easy for you as an end
user to do it yourself.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
PETER HAZLEHURST:
You're welcome.
Hi.
AUDIENCE: I was wondering if
there are any more active ways
with interacting with
the customer?
Because the situation you
described in the presentation
was more like a passive one.
The customer has to
find this coupon
on a web page somewhere.
And if he saves this coupon
to the Wallet, then
he you can use it.
But are there any ways for the
retailer to shoot coupons to
the customers who have
checked into the
location, or who are nearby?
PETER HAZLEHURST: Yeah.
So it's actually, so I'm just
demonstrating the sort of the
normal, Hey, I was searching
for goods and
services through the web.
But the APIs aren't limited
to that use case.
You could totally apply it to if
you see a check-in in your
store, you could push a coupon
into their Wallet.
You could do that today.
I think if you go to our booth
downstairs, you'll see an
example of tapping
an NFC poster.
And that pushes the coupon
into your Wallet.
The API itself is very
broad and generic.
We're making it very easy
to integrate in multiple
different use cases.
AUDIENCE: Curious about the
emphasis on the OAuth APIs to
add your credit cards.
Do you find users are
not inclined to
enter the data manually?
Or take a photo of
their cards?
You know, OCR it?
Is that something users
don't want to do?
PETER HAZLEHURST: We find
a couple of issues.
One is it's just a pain.
So it's an effort to do it.
And discovering Google Wallet
as an endpoint to do that,
rather than being able to be in
online banking and getting
a notification that you can
now push your cards into
Google Wallet, actually creates
another channel for
people to be aware that Google
Wallet even exists.
And we focused in
on simplicity.
Making it really, really easy.
All you have to do is trust your
bank, which you generally
do, to Google.
And then you're going to be
able to push information.
And the upshot of that
is that the banks
could also push changes.
So if, for example, your card
expires, or it runs out, or
you get a new card issued they
can push the changes, as well,
without you having to
be involved anymore.
And that's a huge advantage
to consumers.
Because we see a lot of people
with cards in their Wallet
that expire over time.
And then when they're about to
make a payment, they're like,
Ugh, OK I have to go and update
it and make a change
and things like that.
And this keeps the issuer
in with a channel
to communicate back.
Cool.
AUDIENCE: Like somebody asked,
the coupons are only for
offline use.
Are there any plans to make them
available for online use,
like you get a coupon on a
website and use it on another
website, for instance.
PETER HAZLEHURST: Yeah.
So we haven't announced anything
in the area around
what we're doing on the
online side of things.
But it's a key area of focus for
us, to make sure that the
coupons and the offers that you
save are available for use
everywhere.
AUDIENCE: All right.
Thanks.
AUDIENCE: You mentioned and
demonstrated the creation of a
coupon on the web page.
Would you mind going into more
detail about how the
redemption works?
The recognition of coupons?
So, say I'm a retailer,
I have a coupon.
How do I know that that user has
my coupon in their Wallet?
Can I look for other coupons
from competitors in their
Wallet when they scan
their phone?
How does that work?
PETER HAZLEHURST: So it's
actually pretty simple in
terms of the redemption path.
So either because of tapping,
we're going to push the coupon
information through Mifare
into the NFC terminal.
Or if it's a show-and-scan
type of thing, then the
cashier is going to physically
take an image of a bar code or
type in the card number.
So at that point, you as the
retailer know this transaction
has come through.
Right now, we haven't made it
possible for a retailer to
look at what else is stored
in the Wallet.
AUDIENCE: So but when I tap that
NFC, do I have the coupon
open on my phone already?
Or does it just look at my
coupons and go, Oh, that's
valid, I'll redeem
that for you.
PETER HAZLEHURST: So let me make
sure-- can you ask the
question again?
Sorry.
AUDIENCE: So I show up at
a store with my phone.
And I want to redeem a coupon.
So when I get to the check-out
I'll just tap in on the NFC.
Do I have to select the coupon
I want to use first?
Or does it figure out, based
on what's in my wallet, Oh,
you're at Walgreen's, here.
Here's this Walgreen's coupon
that you saved previously,
I'll use that.
PETER HAZLEHURST: So basically,
what you're going
to want to do is choose the one
that you want to be active
at that point in time.
And then it's going
to passed through.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Cool.
PETER HAZLEHURST: OK?
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
PETER HAZLEHURST: OK.
Well it doesn't look like we
have any more questions.
I really want to thank you
guys for your time this
morning and encourage you to
come and check out some of the
new ways to add information
to your Wallet.
And then we're looking for
feedback on other sorts of
categories of information you
want to store, as we start to
broaden this out and make it
available across everywhere
that Google Wallet's accepted.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]